[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen servicewelt
ich glaube auch meinem wechsel haben
habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon erkannt
dass es heute eine torte zu halloween
gibt viele meiner zuschauer haben mich
wieder gefragt ob ich denn nicht wieder
eine halloween torte machen kann
und hier steht sie nun auf den ersten
blick könnte man vielleicht gar nicht
meinen dass es wirklich halloween torte
ist aber ist es wirklich
ich habe hier vorne nämlich eigentlich
sich drauf und zwar ist es die la
catrina la catrina wurde im letzten
jahrhunderts zur figur der toten
sozusagen also durch diese figur gedenkt
man den toten in mexiko und zwei füße
figur ein skelett was sehr böse kleidung
trägt und auch einen ganz großen hut und
so möchten wir im prinzip die obere
soziale schicht so ein bisschen ja wie
soll ich sagen ein bisschen kritisieren
und soll einfach über die tage hinweg
also über halloween bis allerheiligen
einfach den toten gedenken und den
gedanken finde ich einfach gar nicht
schlecht an halloween war ja auch der
grundgedanke dass man den kot toten
gedenkt auch an allerheiligen ist es ja
so und auch in vielen anderen religionen
und kulturen ist es wirklich so man soll
einfach die toten nicht vergessen immer
gebete aussprechen und deswegen fand ich
das eine ganz schöne geste einfach mal
mit la catrina eine torte zu machen
die figur ist so ist ein skelett wie
schon gesagt mit einem pompösen gewandt
und mittlerweile wird werden auch ganz
viele tattoos in diesem stil gemacht und
eben nicht mehr im skelett tätowiert
sondern einfach nur schöne figur wo
ebenso ein bisschen skelett gesichtszüge
sozusagen gemacht werden
daher habe ich jetzt hier oben eine
torte innen ist es eine regenbogen torte
hier vorne habe ich das gesicht gesicht
auf gezeichnet und gemalt und hier oben
habe ich einfach ein bisschen deko was
den hut so ein bisschen darstellen soll
und hier unten dran die torte das soll
dann das pompöse gewarnt sein also das
bunte schöne kleid und ich denke es ist
mal eine richtig coole vor allem sehr
bunte halloween idee und ich zeige euch
jetzt wie ich die torte hergestellt habe
und startet zuerst einmal mit dem
schokoladen track für den unteren boden
los geht's mit der unteren etage dafür
habe ich schon mal einen schokokuchen
vorbereitet und zwar ist es der kuchen
da ein bisschen stabiler ist und da gibt
es auch schon ein rezept
basics den habe ich jetzt mit 24
zentimetern durchmessern gebacken und
auch bereits gestern schon gebacken
das heißt schon über nacht abgekühlt
jetzt schneide ich den zwei mal durch
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt einen torten
drehteller und habt ihr eigen kickboard
habe ich mal einfach zugeschnitten auf
24 5 cm durchmesser und zwar deswegen
bin ich jetzt die torte gleich darauf
lege habe ich so einen minimalen rand
und da ist immer perfekt dafür dass ich
dann eben die ganz schön glatt streichen
kann die torte wird gefüllt und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier 160 gramm zart beta
gamma und 160 gramm airplus butter und
die werden jetzt gleich vermischt es
gibt einen richtig tollen geschmack und
dann habe ich hier noch ein bisschen
aprikosenmarmelade und selbstgemachter
orangenmarmelade gemischt da könnt ihr
einfach eine marmelade nach wahrnehmen
und für den kreis habe ich hier noch ein
paar erdnüsse die mit rein kommen also
die torte wird richtig lecker wird so
eine art necas torte
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich ein bisschen von berkant
streiks auf die platte um sitzt den
ersten boden schon mal drauf
[Musik]
jetzt setze hier den ersten boden drauf
und dann kommt zuerst die marmelade
drauf dann die füllung und dann die
erdnüsse
ich habe sie bilden ein bisschen schief
geschnitten aber das ist gar nicht
schlimm das kann man nämlich immer ganz
gut mit erfüllung ausgleich
[Musik]
die torten schließlich immer gerne
entweder mit dem mittelstück oder mit
dem unteren teil hab damit sie einfach
schön eben werden
und jetzt stelle ich die torte in den
kühlschrank für etwa eine stunde damit
sie schon fest wird und dann kommt strom
herum noch eine zar peter karrasch der
zwischenzeit kann ich euch schon mal
zeigen wie ich die zweite torte fülle
die obere torte hat einen durchmesser
von 18 cm
und die ist wirklich richtig schön bunt
innen und außen
ich habe es bereits zehn tortenböden
vorgebacken gestern
und zwar habe ich jetzt dafür meine
lieblings teilgenommen für den teig
brauche ich drei eier 150 g zucker etwas
salz etwas von den extrakt 50 milliliter
milch 100 milliliter mineralwasser 150
milliliter sonnenblumenöl 200 gramm
eineinhalb teelöffel backpulver 100
gramm gemahlene mandeln und hier habe
ich noch lebensmittelfarbe in
verschiedenen farben
die eier werden jetzt gemeinsam mit dem
zucker dem salz und dem mangel extrakt
in etwa vier bis fünf minuten sec remich
verrührt
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich noch die flüssigen
zutaten also milch mineralwasser und
sonnenblumenöl dazu und rühre diese
zutaten bei niedriger stufe 1
jetzt führe ich noch das mehl mit dem
backpulver und gebt die gemahlenen
mandeln in den teig und höhere die
zutaten ganz vorsichtig ein
[Musik]
aus dieser teig portion entstehen jetzt
vier teigboden deswegen gebe ich jetzt
einen esslöffel teig jeweils in ein
separates schälchen und kann jetzt ein
bisschen lebensmittel wasser dazugeben
hier müsste jetzt einfach nur beachten
dass er genügend verpasste dazu gibt
denn wenn jetzt gleich der restlichen
teig dazu kommt dann wird die farbe ein
bisschen heller
zum schluss wird der teig auf die
schildchen aufgeteilt 100 teig kann mit
der farbe verrührt werden jetzt für dich
den teig in die backe ein diese habe ich
bereits auf 18 cm eingestellt und da
passen jeweils zwei stück auf ein blech
und jeweils vier stück gemeinsam in
einen ofen
die teile werden jetzt im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad heißluft etwa 17
bis 20 minuten gebacken bis sie gar sind
und diese portion werde ich jetzt noch
eineinhalb mal zu bereiten so dass ich
noch mal sechs boden zu bereiten und
insgesamt zehn blüten erhalten weil sie
jetzt keine zehn böden möchtet dann
könnt ihr natürlich auch weniger
zubereiten aber bei mir wird es gleich
eine richtig schöne hohe torte wichtig
ist einfach dass sie am vortag
zubereitet werden und damit sie einfach
schön abgekühlt sind die kümmel dann
auch nicht mehr so sehr und sie sind
einfach viel stabiler
ich habe ich jetzt schon mal wieder ein
kickboard zugeschnitten das hat ein
bisschen mehr als 19 zentimeter im
durchmesser
da kommt jetzt weiße ganache drauf und
ich starte jetzt mit einem schoko boden
den könnt ihr entweder einfärben oder
nehmt einfach ein bisschen kakaopulver
und mischt unter und gefüllt wird die
torte jetzt mit einer 40 maracuja
marmelade die habe ich bereits püriert
damit sie einfach ein bisschen flüssiger
wird und zwischen die böden kommt dann
einfach ein bisschen weißer hirsch und
so entsteht gleich die schöne hohe torte
[Musik]
beide torten mindestens eine stunde
gekühlt jetzt sind sie schön fest und
bei dieser torte hier habe ich so
gemacht ich habe einen torten retter
noch draufgelegt und das ganze dann
umgedreht und so wurde einfach die
oberfläche jetzt richtig schön platt
jetzt nämlich die restliche karsch und
streiche jetzt die schicht darauf
erstmal eine erste schicht zum kreml
binden damit sie noch mal kühl gestellt
und dann mit der zweiten schicht ganz
glatt gestrichen
[Musik]
die taten sind jetzt beide glatt
gestrichen die untere torte überzählig
jetzt mit schwarzem sondern ich habe ich
jetzt bereits ein kilo schwarzen von
dann weiß geknetet und die rolle eben
auf etwas becker strecke denn aus
[Musik]
die tochter ist jetzt eine schöne
trockene oberfläche daher werde ich
setzen ist das bak transfer einsprühen
davon sind besser halt hat
[Musik]
und jetzt lege ich die decke noch
darüber streichen von dann von oben nach
unten klappen dann die überreste weg
hier oben möchte ich jetzt eine richtig
schöne scharfe kante daher werde ich
jetzt die torte einmal umdrehen also
nehme ich eine tortenplatte drunter und
eine oben drüber und dre die torte
vorsichtig um
das habe ich angestrengt
das ist nicht so blöd ausschaut jetzt
seht ihr hier unten diese lücken und die
könnte jetzt mit dem torten blätter
einfach so ein bisschen nach unten
drücken und dann bekomme ich richtig
schöne scharfe kanten
[Musik]
die torte gefällt mir jetzt echt gut
jetzt stelle ich sie noch mal in den
kühlschrank und kann jetzt die obere
torte auch mit von dann überziehen
da nehme ich aber den weißen
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt verschiedene farben
von dort vorbereitet und zwar habe ich
immer einen teil von dann mit einem teil
blüten pasta gemischt um modelliermasse
herzustellen
diese teile rolle ich jetzt ganz schön
aus das könnt ihr entweder mit einem
ausrutscher machen sich nämlich sehr
edel maschine weil es einfach ein
bisschen schneller geht und diese teig
streifen werden dann zu dünnen streifen
zugeschnitten
[Musik]
die lediglich auf eine silikon matte ihr
könnt aber auch frischhaltefolie oder
zum beispiel die dauer backt folie
nehmen und dann einfach abdecken denn
durch die brötchentaste trocknen die
ziemlich schnell und jetzt bereite ich
noch die restlichen farben vor
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alle streifen vorbereitet
und jetzt gebe ich sie hier an die torte
am ende soll es aussehen wie sonnen
rüschenrock ich werde jetzt allerdings
nicht von unten nach oben anfangen
sondern von oben nach unten
so ist es ein bisschen einfacher das
heißt hier kommt jetzt ein bisschen
kleber an den rand der torte
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt die streifen und
legt sie an die torte und legte so ein
bisschen entfalten und das mache ich
einfach immer eine reihe eine farbe und
dann kommt einfach kunterbunt drauf
[Musik]
jetzt geht es mit der oberen torte
weiter die durfte ja ein bisschen aus
herten das heißt der von dann ist nicht
mehr ganz so weit wie vorhin und jetzt
habe ich hier eine vorlage und zwar habe
ich mir da im gesicht gezeichnet das
soll praktisch diese la catrina sein und
das ganze sieht jetzt ein bisschen
realistisch aus das heißt ich mache
keinen skelett gesicht sondern ein
menschliches gesicht nun mal das geld
sozusagen drauf und die vorlage können
wir dann ausschneiden und hin heben und
ein paar stellen die markiere ich mir
jetzt mit einem spitzen gegenstand eine
nadel zum beispiel und dann werde ich
lebensmittel verpasste und stifte und
metallic farben nehmen um das ganze zu
bemalen
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt die lebensmittel
farbstifte die sind wirklich super damit
könnt ihr das komplette gesicht
aufzeichnen
die unterlage muss einfach ein bisschen
an getrocknet sein und damit könnt ihr
alles schon zeichnen und natürlich auch
aus marl
ich werde allerdings noch metallic
farben und auch früh haben nehmen um das
ganze einfach noch ein bisschen schöner
auszugestalten und ich fange jetzt
einfach an und ihr schaut mir dabei so
[Musik]
die torte sitz fertig bemalt jetzt
kommen da noch ein paar blumen drauf und
es sind wirklich super schnelle blumen
dafür braucht ihr nur ein bisschen
modischen rollator mit der funktioniert
nämlich am besten und am ende sehen die
blumen so aus als es sind so sehen aus
wie so stoffhosen und so genau so soll
es auch sein
dafür nimmt die modelle schokolade und
rollte aus
jetzt habe ich so ungefähr einen
millimeter stark jetzt wird ein breites
band zurechtgeschnitten das könnt ihr
auch mit einem messer zum beispiel
machen
das kann ich jetzt halt bären also es
muss jetzt auch nicht zu lange seien und
jetzt nehmt ihr das eine falte des um
ungefähr so und hier oben
diesen aderlass tier so also nicht zu
drücken und jetzt nehmt ihr das ganze in
die hand und zwirbelt einfach um die
eigene achse und könnte immer mal wieder
den stoff innen drin in falten legen
also den stoff die vor die tür
schokolade und am ende hier einfach noch
ein drehen zu drücken und dann mit einer
schere wegschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt meine rosen fertig und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr noch ein bisschen
blaue pullover farbe nehmen jetzt einen
leichten metallic effekt und die dann
noch so ein bisschen damit ein pudern
jetzt nehme ich die rosen und setzte
hier oben auf die torte das soll jetzt
sozusagen wie der hut sein also den hut
darstellen
und da setze ich jetzt noch ein paar von
den blumen mit rein
ihr könnt aber auch rosen hier schon am
kaufen das team ist ja auch nicht selber
machen die lücken werde ich mit den
blättern wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen
einfach aus dekorieren und dann nehme
ich hier noch ein paar diamanten dafür
dass er seine strecke und diese nämlich
auch richtig schön farbenfroh und schön
[Musik]
ich bin die torte sieht richtig gut aus
und jetzt wird der angeschnitten zum
anschneiden könnte jetzt entweder die
torte oben anschneiden fertigessen und
dann die untere anschneiden
oder wenn ihr gleich beide torten essen
möchte so wie ich oder wir spielen sie
allein essen könnt ihr die obere torte
weg sitzen denn da habe ich eine platte
drunter und ich schneide zuerst einmal
die untere an die stäbe muss man halt
zum essen dann raus nehmen also das
müsst ihr dann euren gästen einfach
sagen
[Musik]
so das erste stück ist immer das
schwierigste und danach geht's einmal
mit erdnussbutter
[Musik]
und hier haben wir ein schönes
kunterbuntes stück also wenn das nicht
schön ist von außen und von innen schön
und jetzt der demokrat nicht da ist zum
probieren
ich teile mit euch kommen wir probieren
alles probieren wir einmal den pink auch
sonst ich gebe die mangels stücke und
erben
[Gelächter]
so jetzt hab ich den mund wieder frei
also ich muss sagen favorit absolut mit
erdnuss erdnussbutter und schokolade und
die ergebnisse mit drin also richtig
toller krems vor allem mit den
gesalzenen erdnüssen bist du wirklich
unbedingt mal ausprobieren da andere
kuchen ist auch sehr lecker sehr saftig
und sehr aromatisch und wie gesagt
gefällt mir einfach insgesamt die torte
vor allem weil sie von außen und von
innen bunt ist und wenn ihr die torte
nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf meinem
blog vorbei ochs blog.de
da steht es noch mal ganz genau und
vielleicht postete ein foto von eurer
halloween pate und schickt uns einfach
ein bild davon also ich freue mich schon
auf eure fotos auf euer feedback und wir
sehen uns nächsten mal wieder bis an
[Musik]